foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
cook the free agent running back joining
us from I believed where are you exactly
Dalvin are you in in New York in
Manhattan
yeah I'm in Manhattan okay are you where
are you on your way to
oh I'm actually leaving good morning
football right now
um I want to grab some food then
that's about it when do you when do you
visit the Jets
well Sunday ooh when do you visit the
Patriots
it's a good question
do you know if you're visiting the
Patriots
no I don't know yet okay but you are
visiting the Jets
yes I am
does this feel like high school when
you're being recruited
it does like been in his position again
um it's fun just going through the
process but it definitely feels like
high school again where do you want to
play
it's a good question upstairs trying to
answer right now um that's why I'm
taking this visit
um
to figure things out to kind of you know
sort these things up and figure that out
how many teams have reached out
that you think are legitimate
legitimately interested
um I think we got quite a few on the
table that's legitimate
they they've been reaching out um give
me a number like five seven nine
probably about five teams okay so about
five I think you should do it like in
high school where you have three hats
there and and then you have a table like
you do a press conference and then you
go and I'm gonna pick up the Florida
state hat
that was pretty good because I didn't
get to do that when I was in high school
I actually went to went to college early
enrolled early so I didn't get to do the
Hat Tricks so that'd be pretty cool uh
when's the last time you talked to Aaron
Rodgers
um
two days ago
you call him he call you
um it was kind of um text message he
just sent me a text message just
reaching out but Dalvin he's given back
money to the Jets to be able to bring in
players uh
how far apart are you with the Jets as
far as money goes
um that's something I that my agent take
care of um but are you close are you
close to hey if they do this they get to
this number you got green on
uh
I guess so well I let him do his job
that's what that's what he that's what
he do I let him do his job I just tell
him that green equals green if you know
what I mean
I definitely know what you mean okay
um why why are you still unsigned though
given what you've done what you did last
year I mean you all you do is rush for a
thousand yards I mean
uh why are you on the outside looking in
I know what I bring to the table um like
you said
I know Diamond cook is and then once the
once the ball gets snapped you know it's
only popping but like I'm not trying to
rush into a situation it's not right for
Daven cook I think that's what you see
around the league a lot of time people
jump to the conclusion and then don't be
the right situation for them so I'm just
trying to you know weigh all my options
and make sure I go into the right
situation for me oh you can't go third
person though
you're not allowed to do that no you
can't go third person you can't go down
like I don't say you know Dan Patrick
you know would like for Dalvin cook to
be able to sign with you can't do that
all right so no third person can't do
that
it's it's one of those things man like
like I said
I bring I bring I bring a lot of value
to the team but like I just don't want
to like be in a situation it's not right
for me and for my family oh I know I'm
just I'm having fun with you going third
person like like Barry Sanders could go
third person okay
I feel that
give me
who's the running back though that you
admired the most growing up who had the
biggest influence on you
um martial oh
how come
um the way the way he
I think he pretty much started the
versatile back the three down back you
know catching the ball at the backfield
you know running those Choice routes you
know obviously you know what he did with
the ball is and I think I I think I
remind myself of him good that's not it
he might be the smartest guy who's ever
played the running back position in my
opinion uh the whole month here with the
running back position and getting paid
here and how does that impact you do you
think
um
I don't know that's a great question
um I feel like I'm gonna get my value
regardless of the position I think
the running back position is at a point
where we're trying to get it back to
where I need to be at but
I don't know I don't know how it impact
me I think that's what we're going to
see coming up in these few weeks I
always wondered what if we let running
backs come out of college after their
sophomore year
that'd be smart I I had a productive
sophomore year I feel like I was ready
to go okay like I was ready to go to the
league well I remember Marshall Faulk
his freshman year or Adrian Peterson his
freshman year Leonard fournette like it
you know give you guys a head start here
because you're going to take so much
wear and tear and the more wear and tear
that nobody wants to sign you if you
rush for 2 000 yards as Nick Chubb said
then nobody wants you because you've got
2 000 yards on your body so the the
better you are it's like it hurts you it
feels like down the road of getting paid
crazy nobody else in the sport is
affected that way
yeah it's a weird position to be in
because like you say if you great at
what you do at the position they want to
give you the ball 350 to 400 times a
year but then you know you run for 1800
yards in the next year
you know you got too much on your body
and they don't want to give you the
money yeah so it's like it's like a
weird a weird position to be in so you
got to kind of time it up perfectly when
you want to go be explosive it's you got
to kind of play a game
uh did Rogers offer you a guest room
until you get your own place in New York
I know he won my I mean Miami chilling
in the basement or something like that
okay hey you'll be roommates you and
Aaron Rodgers it'll be great uh well
good luck this weekend and thanks for
joining us good to talk to you again
that's uh Dalvin cook
yeah go to the Jets on Sunday what do
you wear